(upbeat background tune riffing)
(distant audience cheering)
- We are back, and Michael
Bublé is here with us!
(distant audience cheering)
Or as I like to say, "My Bublé".
He's got a new whiskey out
called Fraser and Thompson.
Music and whiskey, they
often go together, everybody.
Uh, but maybe nowhere more
often than at the legendary
Whisky a Go Go club on Sunset
Boulevard in Hollywood.
So, in honor of Michael's
whiskey, in honor of you,
it's time for a game
called "Whisky a Go Go,
How Much Do You Know Know?"
(distant audience cheering)
♪ Whisky a Go Go ♪
♪ How much do you know know ♪
(distant Michael laughing)
That is the worst, greatest thing ever.
I, I love my writers.
I'm look, I'm looking...
Or did y'all write that?
Is that all y'all?
Oh, you're like, "We aren't claiming it."?
(Kelly laughing)
All right, I'm looking for, for, Lord,
I'm looking for you to help us out.
Can you?
(background artists ethereal vocalizing)
(distant audience cheering)
- [Announcer Thompson] Well,
I certainly can, Kelly.
And happy new year to you.
And also to you, Mi Bublé.
- [Kelly] Mi Bublé...
(Kelly clapping)
(distant audience applauding)
- [Announcer Thompson] All
right, now, here's what's
happening in this game.
- Okay.
- [Announcer Thompson] I'm
gonna give you a clue for
a musician or a band,...
and your hint is that this
musician or band once performed
at the Whisky a Go Go.
- Okay.
- [Announcer Thompson]
But there's a twist.
If you hit your button and
you answer incorrectly,
you've got to drink
some of Bublé's whiskey.
Mmm hmm.
(distant audience playful groaning)
We also got some non-alcoholic
drinks out there too,
if you want.
Always drink responsibly.
- Okay,...
- [Announcer Thompson]
Okay, Kelly and Michael,
you're each playing to win a big prize
for your side of the audience.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Announcer Thompson] I can't
remember what the prize is.
(audience cheering)
That's right.
I can't remember what the prize is,
'cause I'm hammered already.
But if you...
- [Kelly] I'm no...
(Michael laughing)
- [Announcer Thompson] If you lose,
you're gonna get eaten
alive by polar bears.
So here we go.
- Oh, man.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Here's your first question.
- That would suck.
- Thank you, God.
- [Announcer Thompson] You're welcome.
- I haven't eaten yet.
I'm nervous.
- [Announcer Thompson] Oh,
this is gonna be fun then.
We gonna have a good time.
I hope you get 'em all wrong.
Here we go.
These guys were actually the
house band at the Whiskey
before they went out as
Riders on the Storm...
(buzzer chiming)
to find...
Michael,...
- That is The Doors, I believe.
- [Announcer Thompson] It is The Doors!
(distant audience cheering)
- You don't have to!
(distant audience applauding)
- What?
- You don't have to drink, does he?
'Cause he got it right, right?
I have to drink, right?
- [Michael] But I thought I won something.
(distant show attendants laughing)
(distant audience applauding)
Okay, just one more.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Everybody's a winner.
- But I won.
- Who made that? - [Kelly] But I won.
- What is this?
- [Kelly] We are a great show.
- It's my Whiskey, but
it's mixed with something.
- It's mixed with miracles.
(distant audience laughing)
- [Announcer Thompson]
Everybody's a winner.
- Okay. - [Announcer Thompson]
- He drank for me.
- [Announcer Thompson] Drink up.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Drink up, butter cup.
Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [Announcer Thompson]
This Orange County Band
gave listeners absolute
certainty that the front lady was
more than just a girl.
(buzzer chiming)
- I knew it was gonna be her.
Okay, No Doubt, No Doubt.
(background bell chiming)
Yes!
- [Announcer Thompson] It's No doubt.
(distant audience applauding)
- [Kelly] I'll drink some to you too.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Go ahead and have a sip.
- Salut! - Salut.
What, what was the clue?
How did you know that?
- She...
They said Orange County band, female led.
Come on.
(distant audience laughing)
- [Announcer Thompson]
I'm gonna take a sip too.
- Okay.
Okay.
(Michael laughing)
- [Announcer Thompson]
Here is your next question.
- That is smooth, man.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Hopefully I can read it.
This pair of British
Brothers once said they were
bigger than the Beatles.
(buzzer chiming)
Michael,...
- Oasis.
(background bell chiming)
- [Announcer Thompson] It is Oasis.
(distant audience applauding)
- Yes!
- [Kelly] I feel like they would say,
"We are bigger than the Beatles."
I feel like they would say that.
Oh, fine.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Have yourself a sip.
Go ahead, take a shot.
Why not?
- [Kelly] I'm sipping responsibly.
I haven't eaten.
(distant audience laughing)
I'm like,...
- [Announcer Thompson] I think
you should have a Chardonnay,
Bublé Chardonnay.
- [Kelly] Bublé Chardonnay.
- [Announcer Thompson] I like that.
Bublé Chardonnay from Marce,
drink the day away with Gourmet Bublé.
Okay, here's your next question.
(distant audience laughing)
(distant audience applauding)
Come on, now.
- That's pretty good!
- [Announcer Thompson] Here we go.
Question number four.
This British brand started with four dudes
before adding a woman
named Stevie to the mix.
- Oh!
(buzzer chiming)
Fleetwood Mac!
- [Announcer Thompson]
It is Fleetwood Mac.
(distant audience cheering)
You got it, Kelly.
We got ourselves a tie.
(background air horn trumpeting)
That noise means that we have
time for one more question.
- [Michael] Oh, and are we tied?
- [Announcer Thompson] And
that we are tied, Michael.
That's correct.
So this one is worth double,
because I'm seeing double.
So here we go.
- Okay, here we go.
- [Announcer Thompson]
This British piano man
played at the whiskey early in his...
(buzzer chiming)
Kelly?
- Elton John.
(background bell chiming)
- [Announcer Thompson] It is Elton John.
(distant crowd cheering)
- {Kelly] Nicely done there,
sweetheart. - Thank you.
- [Announcer Thompson] And we've done it.
The whiskeys run out. - Nicely done.
- [Announcer Thompson]
Kelly is the winner.
(distant audience cheering)
- Salut.
- [Michael] She said,...
- That is really good.
- She said she was gonna kick my butt.
- I did.
- [Michael] She said, "I'm
gonna kick your butt."
And she did.
- [Kelly] I only speak truth.
I am not joking when I
say this is really good.
- [Michael] Thank you.
- I wouldn't have brought
it up again and again,
but it's really good.
(distant audience applauding)
Um, but if you come to my
show, everyone's a winner!
So everyone,...
(distant audience cheering)
this is a great gift for all
of you who like to write,
like Michael and myself.
The Moleskine notebook is
inspired by the legendary
notebooks used by artists and thinkers
over the past two centuries.
Moleskins collections
include the New Year's
Artist Collection, I love New
York, and Python planners.
Ooh, I like Python planners.
(distant Michael laughing)
To unleash your human genius y'all,
you're all going home with
a $300 moleskin gift card.
(distant audience cheering)
Thank you, Lord, for joining us today!
Again, Michael's Whiskey is
called Fraser and Thompson,
and it's delicious.
It's available online, and
at select spirits retailers.